l'été a enfin posé ses valises à
montigny le bretonneux
la huitième édition de l'été en sable a
commencé samedi des châteaux sont
édifiés sur le parking du gymnase alain
colas pendant que certains prennent le
train sur le terrain de basket des
activités sportives et culturelles sont
mises en place chaque jour pour les
familles et les jeunes comme il ya
beaucoup de monde s'amuse et tous et
familiale ya aussi pour les ados pour
les tout petits
il ya des structures gonflables enfin je
trouve ça bien pour je suis tous les
gens de montigny et puis d autres villes
comme l'année dernière j'ai ramené des
gens ma famille dit alice soit amusé ici
alors qu'il parle pas français
et en plus c est convivial parce que
avant ma cheminée ces personnes ça a
permis de connaître des jambes et de
plus socialisées un mot d'ordre la bonne
humeur
vingt-quatre mille entrées sont prévues
cet été les organisateurs se prépare à
accueillir petits et grands le but de ce
dispositif que tout le monde ait droit à
des vacances c'est à la fois de pouvoir
prolonger les vacances pour les
personnes qui partent mais c'est aussi
et surtout de pouvoir va permettre un
cadre de loisirs un cadre de vacances
aux personnes qui qui restent sur place
il y en a encore qui m'ont dit ce matin
que c'était dommage finalement il est
pourquoi partir alors qu'ils avaient
tout sur place c'est vrai qu'il ya selon
les journées selon le temps il ya quand
même une ambiance qui est plutôt
sympathique et qui nous permet ainsi de
proposer pas mal de choses et donc on a
des retours très positifs d'année en
année des sorties sont également
proposés l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin ou encore le parc astérix
l'occasion de s'évader pour les inhibant
pain jusqu'au 21 août